(upbeat music)
- I'm Jan Kingaard, CEO of
King Size Bows Incorporated,
and welcome to my bow kingdom.
We're in the joy business.
We make special occasions special.
I have to say that our most popular bow
is our signature monarch
bow, the red and silver one.
The Lexus commercials, that
we've had the privilege of doing
for the last eight years,
has really drawn attention
to the multi-loop bows.
We're the only ones in the United States
who actually make those bows.
We make them out of a variety
of fabrics and textures,
and those are the ones that
people are most interested in.
There's a whole bow language
that most people don't speak,
but there are definitely
differences of opinions
about how many loops, how
long the tails should be,
and whether there's a
V-cut or an angled cut.
We are pleased to be on
every showroom from Ferrari,
to the Mini, to the Ford, to BMW.
Now, we've found that
customers really expect to keep
the bow when they buy the car.
They wanna drive away with the bow.
You'd be surprised where people put bows,
it's not just on top of a car.
Any place that you wanna
say, look at me, look at me.
It can be on a bicycle,
or a surf board, or skis,
on a gate, on the top of
your house at a pinnacle.
Once you put a bow on it, it's a present.